francia está en una situación grave en
noviembre será un mes extenuante y las
muertes seguirán aumentando ese fue el
tono de la conferencia de prensa que dio
ron castex el primer ministro de francia
en la tarde de este jueves acompañado de
alguno de sus ministros el primer
ministro galo anunció una ampliación del
toque de queda a 38 departamentos más a
partir de la medianoche de este viernes
y una medida pues que regirá a partir
del sábado de 9 de la noche a 6 de la
mañana por espacio de seis semanas con
este anuncio ya son 54 los departamentos
en donde hay un 'toque de queda' además
de la polinesia francesa y 46 millones
de habitantes que se ven afectados por
esta medida
castex se dijo que para frenar esta
epidemia se necesita la de trabajo de
todos y que de no ser así pues va a
tener que tomar unas medidas mucho más
duras el ministro de salud también
aprovecho para tomar la palabra durante
esta rueda de prensa y dijo que se
espera la próxima semana se haga una
evaluación de la eficacidad o no de esta
medida de toque de queda también se
presentó rápidamente la aplicación de
rastreo para coronavirus una nueva
aplicación mucho más personalizada y en
la que se podrán consultar datos diarios
de la epidemia a nivel nacional y a
nivel local por último esta vez si se le
dio un poco de importancia al sector de
la cultura uno de los más afectados por
estas medidas de especial del toque de
queda la ministra de cultura- joslin
bucks lo estaba presente y anunció
ayudas suplementarias por 115 millones
de euros para las salas de cine los
espectáculos los autores y los técnicos